a été la pointe de ce qu'on appelle ici
le triangle de la mort
il se dessine entre 3 cliniques San
Ramon Santa Cristina et la maternité au
tonnelles dans ce triangle les bébés ont
été volés à grande échelle le scénario
sera le même qu'ailleurs des mères
célibataires fragiles à qui l'on annonce
la mort de leur bébé
le cimetière de syndr roquet en
Andalousie dans le sud de l'Espagne
toutes les semaines Arthuro vient se
recueillir ici devant la tombe de son
fils
une tombe nue sans fleurs sans nom
il y a quelques années encore elle
portait celui de son bébé mort quelques
jours après sa naissance en septembre
mais récemment l'impensable est arrivé
alors qu'il doit faire des travaux sur
son caveau Arturo veut récupérer les
restes de son fils dans le cercueil
qu'il fait ouvrir pas un ossement la
tombe de son enfant est vide
ma femme m'avait cousu cette petite
poche pour qu'on puisse y mettre les
zones notre fils
résous Reyes peignant
et la date de sa mort 17 septembre 1987
vert grand comme ça et un peu de gaz
chirurgical et rien de plus rien
un cercueil vide et une révélation pour
Arturo
des tranches souvenirs lui reviennent à
l'époque les médecins ne l'ont pas
laissé voir le corps du bébé ne lui
donnant qu'un cercueil déjà scellé
24 ans je ne sais plus comment le dire
bon état où est-il c'est ce que je
voudrais savoir parce que pour l'instant
je ne sais rien
l'histoire d'Arturo est celle
que vieux familles espagnoles
aujourd'hui
dans d'autres cimetières c'est le même
scénario des cercueils sont ouverts
vides pour la plupart nous avons
récupéré ces images d'exhumation
destinées à la police scientifique
tournée en juin dernier dans les
Asturies l'Espagne creuse retourne la
terre ouvre de toutes petites tombes à
la recherche de la vérité
[Musique]
mon histoire a été la première à sortir
au grand jour en Espagne la première et
à partir de mon cas les gens ont
commencé à se bouger ils se sont rendus
compte
à mon fils est mort mais je n'ai pas vu
son corps qu'est-ce qui s'est passé les
gens ont commencé à se poser des
questions à aller dans les cimetières et
à se rendre compte que les cercueils
étaient vides
que sont devenus ces bébés déclarés
morts dont on n'a jamais vu les cadavres
depuis quelques mois le scandale éclate
en Espagne il est en passe de devenir
une affaire d'État
on parle de centaines de milliers de
bébés volés de réseaux d'adoption
occulte d'un gigantesque trafic
d'enfants
nous avons décidé d'enquêter sur un des
plus terribles secrets de la société
espagnole
[Musique]
la première étape de notre enquête nous
emmène à Grenade à la rencontre des
victimes de ce trafic
nous sommes au mois de juin dernier 200
personnes sont au rendez-vous de ce que
l'Espagne appelle la caravane des bébés
volées un gigantesque tour du pays villa
Préville organisé par anadir
l'association des victimes des vols
d'enfants
à chaque étape l'organisation se pose le
temps d'une journée pour offrir son aide
et ses conseils
le guide de cette caravane c'est lui
Antonio il a fondé l'association il a
moins d'un an il est devenu la voie et
le visage des enfants volés
bonjour à tous je suis là pour vous dire
que l'union fait la force il faut qu'on
soit tous ensemble pour qu'on nous
écoute
très vite le public va prendre la parole
et c'est comme une autre réunion qui
commence car ces gens-là sont venus
avant tout pour parler raconter les
histoires que personne n'a voulu
entendre pendant des années traité de
fou ou ignoré pour la première fois ils
peuvent enfin s'exprimer
ma mère disait toujours que le bébé
était très joli une petite brune avec
des boucles mais quand elle a été la
chercher on lui a dit qu'elle était
morte avant de mourir on l'avait baptisé
et appelé Marie des anges
moi je dis que je veux savoir que si ma
soeur est vraiment morte je veux voir
ses restes
j'ai demandé pourquoi vous ne me donnez
pas le corps comme ça je l'entère chez
moi près de ma famille on m'a répondu
madame nous on s'occupe d'enterrer les
enfants vous le laissez ici
ils m'ont dit il est déjà enterré dans
la fosse commune ils m'ont dit aussi
cette phrase tu as déjà beaucoup
d'enfants pourquoi en veux-tu un de plus
tu es un ouvrier est une arrives déjà
pas à nourrir ce que tu as pourquoi tu
en veux le plus
différentes versions mais d'une même et
seule histoire le scénario qui s'est
répété en Espagne pendant des décennies
a quasiment toujours été le même
systématisé massif il concerne au final
des milliers de personnes
il y a des cas dans toutes les régions
d'Espagne plus dans certaines moins dans
d'autres mais toutes sont concernés à
combien vous estimez le nombre d'enfants
volés on pense que 300 000 bébés ont été
volés dans le pays
300 000 bébés volés depuis la guerre
civile espagnole car la tradition est
ancienne elle remonte en fait à
l'Espagne de Franco volé des enfants est
à l'époque un projet politique
1939 fin de trois ans de guerre civile
le général Franco et son armée
l'emportent sur la République
malheur aux vaincu la répression sera
terrible
[Musique]
Franco met en place une dictature
d'extrême droite basée sur deux piliers
le nationalisme et le catholicisme dans
l'Espagne nouvelle la race doit être
régénérée une purification qui passe par
l'enlèvement des enfants d'opposants
un homme agusto Valero le psychiatre
militaire du régime va théoriser
scientifiquement le vol des enfants dans
son étude psychologie du fanatisme
marxiste il établit que les rouges sont
des malades mentaux conclusion les
enfants doivent leur être retirés pour
être rééduqués il n'hésite pas à écrire
nous avons montré dans nos travaux le
lien intime entre marxisme et
infériorité mentale la séparation des
enfants dès le premier moment et la
seule façon de libérer la société de
cette plaie dès la fin de la guerre le
régiment lève les enfants de rouge à
leur famille dans les prisons on retire
leur bébé au républicaine qui viennent
d'accoucher
nouveau-né ou enfant déjà grand ils
seront adoptés par des familles
franquistes ou placés dans des
orphelinats baptisés Centre d'Aide
Sociale
[Musique]
la femme espagnole s'occupe désormais de
sa tâche sacrée récupérer des milliers
d'enfants Espagnols les sauvés de la
misère les rendre plus sains et
régénérer à la batterie qui les a vu
naître le crime devient presque parfait
grâce à un décret adopté le 4 décembre
1941 ce texte permet de changer
définitivement les noms des enfants
enlevés leurs familles ne pourront plus
jamais les retrouver
c'est l'histoire qui a vécu Libertad
fille d'un anarchiste rebaptisé Carmen
par les franquistes elle est aujourd'hui
encore imprégnée des chansons fascistes
de son enfance
[Musique]
tous les jours nous les enfants du
centre
son père anarchiste prend 20 ans de
prison à la fin de la guerre Carmen est
séparée de sa famille et élevé dans un
centre elle y apprend le catéchisme à
servir la messe
on était presque toutes des filles de
rouge et des pires la regarder c'est moi
Carmen apprend surtout à renier les
idées de son père
[Musique]
l'idée c'était on va prendre ces bâtards
de rouge et on va les éduquer dans la
pensée fonkiste nationaliste et
catholique
on avait des prières toutes les heures
des Rosaires les exercices spirituels
tout il fallait dire la messe
on vivait comme des religieuses comme
dans un couvent
on allait devenir l'Espagne nouvelle la
nouvelle phalange espagnole c'était la
nouvelle aube de l'Espagne et les rouges
qui brûlent en enfer sans pitié
un lavage de cerveau sur des enfants
très efficaces malgré son changement
d'identité le père de Carmen parviendra
à la retrouver alors qu'elle est âgée de
20 ans mais la demoiselle franquiste
qu'elle est devenue ne voudra pas
renouer avec lui
[Musique]
comme elle 30 000 enfants de
républicains ont été à l'époque séparés
de leur famille mais le plus incroyable
est que le trafic va continuer bien
après la mort de Franco en 1975 jusqu'à
la fin des années 80
monser un goût a écrit plusieurs
ouvrages sur le sujet elle a montré
comment au bébé volait du franquisme
succède les enfants volés de la
démocratie
à la fin des années 30 vers la fin de la
guerre et au début des années 40
l'objectif du vol des enfants et
politiques c'est la répression politique
le châtiment la punition exercée sur les
opposants mais tout ça va se transformer
dans les années 50 et 60 on va passer à
une répression morale
les mers mineurs les célibataires on ne
va pas laisser exercer leurs droits
d'être mère
et tout cela va plus loin dans les
années 60 70 et jusqu'à présent
les années 80 l'objectif se transforme
en raison économique on passe au trafic
d'enfants
change
deux années quasiment industrielle
type de terreur politique il se
transforme en pratique répété dans les
cliniques et les couvents de 30000
enfants volés sous la dictature on passe
à 300 000 bébés volés de l'Espagne
moderne
[Musique]
nous nous rendons à Barcelone au siège
de l'association anadir qui représente
ses enfants volés nous y retrouvons
Antonio son fondateur
depuis l'an dernier c'est là qu'il
reçoit par centaines adhésion et
témoignages
à madir a été créé quand un ami
d'enfance d'Antonio lui a révélé la
vérité il est un enfant volé ses parents
l'ont acheté le jour de sa naissance
[Musique]
mon ami m'appelle et me dit Antonio je
suis à l'hôpital mon père va mourir et
il vient de m'avouer que toi et moi on
nous a acheté à Saragosse à un curé et à
une bonne soeur je lui dis mais non
c'est impossible tous mes papiers sont
en règle je ne suis pas un enfant adopté
il me répond non tout est faux tout est
falsifié alors j'ai fait un test ADN
avec ma mère le résultat était négatif
elle n'est pas ma mère
[Musique]
ah la vie d'Antonio bascule il abandonne
tout quitte son travail pour créer son
association et rechercher sa véritable
mère
je me suis sentie tellement mal le ciel
est tombé sur la tête tu te rends compte
que tu as vécu toute ta vie dans le
mensonge tu te sens comme un objet parce
que les familles comme la mienne on les
faisait payer par trade sur des années
comme un appartement à crédit
comme un appartement à crédit comme on
achète une voiture
à force de questions sa mère lui a
raconté toute son histoire dans ses
moindres détails stérile elle a été le
chercher en 1969 à Saragosse chez une
religieuse avant de faire faire de faux
papiers à l'enfant aujourd'hui Antonio a
porté plainte pour séquestration et
falsification d'identité
nulle part il n'est marqué que c'est une
adoption
en fait je ne suis pas adopté je suis
tout simplement volé
dans son livret de famille comme sur son
acte de naissance Antonio est inscrit
comme le fils biologique et légitime
d'Antonio et Maria ses parents adoptifs
faut également le lieu où il serait né
l'hôpital cité ne possède aucune trace
de l'enfant même sa date de naissance
est en réalité inconnue le tout frappé
du Saut du ministère de la Justice
donné par une religieuse dans les années
60 Antonio est sans doute née dans une
casse à kuna traduction une maison
berceau tenue par l'Église ce sont des
foyers pour mère célibataire on y
recueille de jeunes filles enceintes qui
veulent cacher leur grossesse ou chassés
par leurs parents les cas sakuna se
multiplient dans les années 50 60 quand
l'église toute puissante impose sa
morale à l'Espagne dans chaque ville des
enfants Inès par centaines de véritables
usines à bébé La plupart des maires
voudront garder leurs enfants beaucoup
n'en n'auront pas la possibilité
nous avons retrouvé une des victimes de
ces cassakunas Vicenta a accouché dans
l'une d'entre elles il y a plus de 40
ans tombé enceinte à l'âge de 15 ans ses
parents la place loin de chez elle dans
une casse à kuna de Valence la vie est
dure austère le prix à payer pour son
péché
les religieuses nous répétaient toute la
journée que ce qu'on avait fait c'était
très mal qu'on était mauvaise et surtout
qu'elles allaient effacer nos péchés je
suppose que le moyen qu'elles avaient
trouvé c'était de nous retirer nos
enfants c'était ça leur solution
malgré les pressions Vicenta répétera
jusqu'au dernier moment vouloir garder
sa fille alors pour pouvoir lui prendre
les religieuses lui diront simplement
que le bébé est mort il y a des
problèmes
j'ai demandé à la bonne soeur où est ma
fille
elle était toute petite elle était très
fragile elle avait deux semaines
d'avance et elle est morte
mais une fille qui était dans la chambre
à côté c'est penché à la fenêtre
un couple est venu de Saragosse un homme
et une femme et ils ont emmené ton bébé
après toute une vie de recherche Vicenta
finira par retrouver sa fille déteste
ADN lui ont confirmé qu'il s'agissait
bien d'elle Susanna a aujourd'hui 43 ans
elle refuse de parler à la presse pour
préserver ses parents adoptifs donner
pour morte à sa naissance elle est la
preuve vivante du mensonge des
religieuses
[Musique]
nous avons voulu en savoir plus sur le
système des kassakouna comprendre
comment elles ont servi pendant des
années de Viviers à bébé nous nous
rendons à Valence là où Vicenta s'est
fait voler son enfant
40 ans plus tard la Casa kuna Santa
Isabelle fonctionne toujours
derrière les murs loin des regards elle
accueille encore des femmes enceintes en
difficulté
le tout se passe dans la plus grande
discrétion toutes nos demandes
d'interview ont été refusées
[Musique]
nous décidons de trouver un autre moyen
pour entrer nous passerons par Annabelle
elle a appris récemment être née dans la
Casa kuna et avoir été donné dans des
circonstances troubles
Annabelle pense qu'elle est une enfant
volée elle va essayer d'en savoir plus
sur sa naissance nous l'accompagnons à
la Casa kuna équipée d'une caméra cachée
nous nous faisons passer pour une amie
[Musique]
Annabelle a demandé à rencontrer la mère
supérieure sœur Irène à défaut de
journalistes elle reçoit régulièrement
des enfants nés ici en quête de leur
identité
sœur irène est arrivé à la casauna dans
les années 60 au plus fort du trafic
elle est la mémoire vive de ce lieu
c'est exactement ce qui s'y est passé
où se passait les accouchements
je vais te montrer c'est par ici
et là au deuxième étage c'est là
qu'elles accouchaient oui c'est ça
nous emmène ensuite dans son bureau pour
discuter ferme sur d'elle elle dit ne
pas pouvoir donner à Annabelle
l'identité de sa mère elle nie en bloc
l'histoire des bébés volés et affirme
avoir tout fait pour le bien des filles
qui venait ici librement
comment ça se passait des parents
venaient ici pour chercher des enfants
sa mère a déposé Annabelle ici un jour
comment ça marchait
[Musique]
non non vous faites des idées les filles
qui venaient ici étaient enceinte celle
qui voulait garder l'enfant elles
étaient libres et elle le faisait et les
autres elle le donna l'adoption c'est
tout
[Musique]
et vous ne notiez pas l'identité des
filles qui a couché ça je ne peux pas le
croire
aujourd'hui on note tout mais à l'époque
ça n'était pas comme ça mon seul
objectif c'était d'éviter les
avortements
bon écoute je vous ai dit tout ce que
j'avais à dire je crois qu'on a déjà
bien parlé
alors c'est bon j'ai dit tout ce que
j'avais à dire mais vraiment on ne peut
rien savoir sur ma mère
Annabelle c'est bon je t'ai dit 50 fois
que je ne te donnerai rien
mais avant de partir sœur Irène va nous
livrer le fond de sa pensée ce qui parle
d'enfants volés veulent juste salir
l'église
ils veulent faire taire l'Église
catholique ça c'est certain
d'après toi qui veut retirer les
crucifix des écoles pourquoi est-ce
qu'ils font tout ça ils veulent en finir
avec l'Église c'est tout ce n'est pas la
première fois qu'ils agissent comme ça
ce Irène n'en dira pas plus pourtant
elle va devoir bientôt répondre à
d'autres questions mais devant un juge
cette fois
car une trentaine de plaintes visent
aujourd'hui la casse à coudre à de
Valence
voici l'homme qui les a déposés Enrique
villa est l'avocat d'Annabelle il est
lui aussi un des 3000 enfants nés dans
la casse à kuna en guerre contre les
religieuses son combat lui a permis de
percer leur secret et leur méthode
voler des bébés leur étaient faciles à
l'époque la loi jusqu'en 87 permet aux
religieuses de se passer du consentement
de la mer
[Musique]
regardez dans mon cas c'est la mer
supérieure de la Casa kuna de Valence
qui certifie l'origine du mineur et
l'abandon volontaire de sa mère il se
conditionnement
une seule personne peut garantir en
Espagne jusqu'en 1997 l'origine du
mineur et le consentement de sa mère
une seule personne qui est la mère
supérieure du centre où il est né
a reçu de l'argent pour cette adoption
comment ça s'est passé et de mettre en
doute le fait que ces mères étaient
vraiment consentantes
pour l'avocat le système se généralise
car le vol de bébé commence à rapporter
beaucoup d'argent
on te dit jamais qu'on vend un enfant on
dit on te trouve un enfant et en échange
tu fais un don à l'église c'est de la
vente dissimulée
en plus d'être volé les bébés étaient
aussi vendus comme de simples objets
l'argent fait son apparition et
transforme un usage en véritable trafic
combien vaut un enfant sur le marché
espagnol des années 70-80 comment se
passent les ventes qui reçoit l'argent
pour le savoir nous cherchons à
rencontrer des parents qui ont payé pour
leur bébé
un sujet évidemment tabou manuel lui
accepte de parler à visage découvert
il est impair acheteur il s'est endetté
pendant des années pour payer son enfant
mais il y a 10 ans Lucas le fils qu'il a
acheté est mort dans un accident à l'âge
de 18 ans
impossible
Lucas il faut être courageux
pardonne-moi
ou que tu sois je reste ton père si je
pouvais parler à ta mère biologique quel
grand jour ce serait
depuis la mort de son fils adoptif
manuel se sent coupable mais aussi libre
de dire la vérité
je vais vous dire si Luca n'était pas
mort
racontait tout ça aurait été
traumatisant pour lui ça aurait été un
choc
mais maintenant je veux le dire au monde
parce que c'est vraiment ce qui s'est
passé
[Musique]
pendant des années manuel et sa femme
ont essayé en vain d'avoir un enfant
jusqu'à ce qu'une amie sage-femme les
appelle
nous sommes alors en 1982 elle leur dit
connaître un moyen de trouver un bébé un
moyen rapide sur mes chers quelques
semaines plus tard elle appelle manuel
et lui donne rendez-vous au pied d'une
clinique de Valence une femme les attend
sur le trottoir c'est elle qui va
récupérer l'argent
on arrive je sors l'argent je le compte
elle le met dans le sac et elle me dit
au revoir direct moi ça ne m'a pas plu
je pensais que quelqu'un m'attendrait à
l'intérieur et qu'on signait les papiers
dans la rue ici
après on monte dans les chambres au 5e
étage
on est monté
on a attendu un peu et quand on nous a
donné l'enfant on s'est dit c'est enfin
pour nous et sa femme
ce jour-là manuel paiera 500 000 pesetas
soit 3000 euros il versera ensuite des
traites pendant plusieurs années
finalement au total combien vous avez
payé autour de 3 millions de PCAS soit
18000 euros
c'était le prix à l'époque d'un bel
appartement d'un très bel appartement
nous on avait une maison qu'on a du
vendre elle coûtait 2 millions de PCAS
si vous ne payez pas que se passait-il
on nous disait qu'on avait intérêt à
payer
ou non aujourd'hui la sage-femme est le
directeur de la clinique sont décédés
mais ce système crapuleux était
généralisé qui soutirait l'argent aux
parents quels sont les bénéficiaires de
ce trafic nous partons à la recherche
des trésoriers de la vente des bébés
pour cela nous retrouvons Antonio le
patron de l'Association des bébés volés
acheter à la naissance il a été payé 200
000 pesetas soit 1500 euros une somme
très importante à l'époque tous les étés
Antonio est allé avec ses parents
remettre une enveloppe à une religieuse
de Saragosse
[Musique]
il vient tout juste de retrouver sa
trace
à plus de 80 ans elle vit dans une
maison de retraite pour religieuse pour
la première fois Antonio va voir en face
la femme qui l'a vendu bonjour
au cours de la conversation la sœur
Belen va reconnaître avoir touché de
l'argent mais elle affirme l'avoir
reversée aux clinique
c'était pour payer les frais
d'accouchement des panés la mer parce
qu'elle restait longtemps parfois une
semaine et les adoptions ensuite ça se
faisait comment légal totalement légal
pourquoi j'ai des papiers qui disent que
je suis un enfant légitime ça ce sont de
faux papiers
qui ne me concerne pas
le dialogue tourne court Antonio préfère
s'en aller bon je vois qu'on peut rien
faire j'espère que tu vas trouver la
paix et que tu vas profiter de l'amour
que ton donner tes parents adoptifs
quelques vœux pieux et une seule réponse
concernant l'argent et il s'agissait de
simples frais pour payer les
accouchements un argument qui ne tient
pas au vu des sommes astronomiques qui
ont été versées
au fil de nos rencontres le nom d'une
clinique revient avec insistance celle
de San Ramon à Madrid c'est dans la
capitale que le trafic aurait atteint
des sommets entre les années 60 et 80
c'est là qu'il serait devenu le plus
abouti le plus criminel aussi
a été la pointe de ce qu'on appelle ici
le triangle de la mort
il se dessine entre 3 cliniques San
Ramon Santa Cristina et la maternité au
tonnelle dans ce triangle les bébés ont
été volés à grande échelle
les employés des trois cliniques
travaillaient ensemble passant les
enfants d'un établissement à l'autre
[Musique]
un acteur clé va apparaître dans notre
enquête le docteur Vella
c'est un gynécologue le fondateur et le
patron de la clinique San Ramon le voici
sur une des rares photos de lui datant
des années 80 le docteur emploie des
religieuses son assistante sœur Maria
travaillent également à Santa Cristina
le scénario sera le même qu'ailleurs des
mères célibataires fragiles à qui l'on
annonce la mort de leur bébé
Mariano Galles avait 23 ans à l'époque
son témoignage est unique hospitalisé à
Sandra mone pour accoucher elle a réussi
à sauver son bébé in extremis pour la
première fois elle revient sur les lieux
où les faits se sont déroulés
et je vais mal je le vis très mal
je pensais pas que j'irai si mal je
croyais avoir oublié
que ces mariages enfin oubliez jamais
mais je croyais que l'angoisse était
passé en fait elle est là
je suis très mal
elle est suivie par le fameux docteur
Vella et son assistante sœur Maria le
scénario habituel se met en place sœur
Maria annonce à la jeune fille que son
bébé est mort mais celle-ci va réagir et
empêcher qu'on lui vole son enfant
à 8h30 ou vers 9h sœur Maria viens me
voir je ne sais plus quelle heure il
était c'était avant 11h elle me dit que
l'enfant est mort qu'il n'y avait plus
rien à faire qu'il avait avalé un
liquide et qu'il était décédé mais moi
j'ai entendu pleurer mon fils
j'ai attrapé ce que je pouvais dans ma
chambre j'ai enfilé mon jean
toutes mes affaires je suis descendu en
courant parce que j'entendais encore son
cri Esther je suis passé devant
l'accueil j'ai descendu un escalier et
je suis arrivé à la salle des bébés mon
fils continuait de pleurer il avait faim
il y avait trois berceaux avec des bébés
j'ai vu mon fils dans le berceau du
milieu et je l'ai pris dans mes bras
essayer de me rattraper par le bras mais
je me suis dégagée je suis sortie de la
clinique en courant et là à la porte
j'ai arrêté un taxi et je suis rentrée à
la maison
Maria réussit à sauver son bébé le
lendemain elle voudra porter plainte
mais en 79 dans la toute jeune
démocratie espagnole les réflexes
franquistes ont la vie dure
le docteur Vella pour les gens c'était
un grand médecin une éminence j'ai dû me
taire j'ai voulu porter plainte j'ai
même été voir les policiers mais comme
j'étais une mère célibataire personne ne
m'a cru ils se sont moqués de moi ils
m'ont dit de partir
à l'époque personne n'écoute Maria
pourtant le nombre de femmes à qui l'on
a comme à elle annoncé la mort de leur
enfant et démesuré dans ses cliniques
résultat des taux de mortalité
disproportionné qui aurait pu alerter la
police et les autorités médicales
combien d'enfants étaient donnés pour
mort chaque mois dans ces maternités
quelle cause de décès était invoquée
nous obtenons un document troublant à
Santa Cristina la clinique où travaille
sœur Maria pour respecter le secret
médical les noms des familles ont été
masqués il recense les morts de
nourrissons du mois de janvier 1964
premier élément frappant on compte 37
morts de bébé en moins d'un mois
dont 5 en moins de 24 heures
une maladie aussi bénigne peut-elle
provoquer la mort d'un nourrisson
existe-t-il des épidémies d'otite nous
sommes allés montrer ce document à une
pédiatrice espagnole pour elle cette
cause de décès est tout simplement
impossible chez un nouveau-né
d'abord on ne peut pas la diagnostiquer
sur un nourrisson l'unique kaolotique
provoque la mort chez l'enfant sait s'il
y a une infection de la mastoïdite c'est
un os interne or cet os ne se développe
que bien après la naissance du bébé de
toute façon dans les années 60 il y
avait des antibiotiques de la
pénicilline le plus gros risque pour un
enfant c'était d'être sourd mais jamais
de mourir
des causes de décès inventées de toutes
pièces qui ont pu là aussi camoufler le
vol d'un enfant
mais c'est clinique vont parfois encore
plus loin dans l'horreur
[Musique]
nous sommes le 4 novembre 1980
des Photoshop de bébé congelés par
exemple dans la presse
c'est l'enquête de German gaygo grand
reporter au magazine Interview
il révèle que des cadavres d'enfants ont
été conservés dans des frigos à la
fameuse clinique San dramon celle que
diriger le docteur Vella
ses cadavres étaient montrés au maire
qui insistait pour voir le corps de
leurs enfants une infirmière de la
clinique et querée par ses pratiques lui
a raconté toute l'histoire
l'infirmière m'a donné rendez-vous une
nuit parce que je n'arrivais pas à le
croire tellement c'était horrible alors
je lui ai dit je veux le voir et comme
je suis photographe je veux le prendre
en photo
à ce moment-là il n'en avait qu'un dans
le frigo il s'en servait comme un alibi
comme un enfant prétexte
quand on disait Homer que leur enfant
était mort certaines souffraient
tellement qu'elle voulait absolument le
voir
elle répétait même s'il est mort je veux
le voir
et comme l'enfant n'était plus là
puisqu'il avait déjà été adopté et bien
on leur montrait le bébé du congélateur
quelques jours après la parution du
reportage la police fera fermer la
clinique
[Musique]
mais le docteur Vella lui ne sera pas
inquiété à 77 ans il exerce encore
aujourd'hui
pourtant c'est son nom qui revient le
plus souvent dans les enquêtes
judiciaires en cours nous nous sommes
procurés les plaintes concernant les
bébés volés déposés devant le parquet de
Madrid plusieurs dizaines d'entre elles
le site nommément
parmi ces plaintes un témoignage lacable
particulièrement c'est celui d'Inès
Madrigal le cadeau du docteur Vella
exceptionnellement sa mère n'a pas payé
pour la voir elle est la bonne d'un ami
du docteur Vella celui-ci décide de lui
offrir un bébé en remerciement pour son
travail
elle met le docteur m'offre à ma mère je
suis un cadeau qui lui fait mais la
vérité surtout c'est que je pense que je
n'étais pas vendable j'étais un bébé
prématuré si tu gâches tes milliers
d'euros le prix d'un appartement est que
finalement le bébé meurt s'est embêtant
mais comme je suis un cadeau c'est moins
grave
dans le cas d'Inès d'après le témoignage
de sa mère c'est le docteur Vella qui
s'occupe de tout il lui remet l'enfant
en main propre avec un document crucial
il s'agit d'un certificat d'accouchement
réalisé au nom de la mer d'Inès pourtant
stérile et âgé de 45 ans il est rempli
par le docteur Vella signé de sa propre
main
il y confirme avoir assisté à
l'accouchement en tant que professionnel
un certificament songé info qui
semblerait prouver l'implication du
docteur Vella
visé par des dizaines de plaintes pour
enlèvement d'enfants accusés par de
nombreuses familles le docteur Vella
semble être une pièce maîtresse du
trafic de bébé
malgré cela il exerce encore à domicile
dans un quartier chic de la capitale
depuis que le scandale a éclaté dans la
presse en janvier 2011 le docteur se
fait très discret il refuse de répondre
au journaliste
nous récupérons son numéro de téléphone
portable et tentons de le joindre pour
le convaincre de nous parler
[Musique]
bonjour vous êtes le docteur Vella oui
c'est moi bonjour Docteur Vella je suis
journaliste pour la télévision française
j'aurais voulu parler avec vous de ce
qui s'est passé dans la clinique San
Ramon à Madrid
je ne veux plus parler
moi j'ai le droit à ce qu'on dise la
vérité et jusqu'à aujourd'hui aucun
journaliste me l'a dit mademoiselle pas
un seul
alors vous allez m'excuser mais je vais
devoir accrocher quelle est la vérité il
n'y a pas eu de vol d'enfant c'était des
adoptions tout était légal
bon excusez-moi mais je ne veux rien
dire je vais raccrocher je raccroche
maintenant vous m'excuserez mais je ne
peux rien faire d'autre
[Musique]
le docteur weila refusera par la suite à
plusieurs reprises de nous parler
nous cherchons alors à rentrer en
contact avec son assistante de l'époque
sœur Maria celle qui d'après Marianne au
gallès a voulu s'emparer de son enfant
la religieuse a vécu plus de 30 ans dans
ce couvent des Filles de la Charité à
Madrid elle est pourtant injoignable
depuis plusieurs mois
nous nous irons donc en filmant
discrètement ses sœurs affirment ne pas
savoir où elle est
je voulais savoir si la soeur Maria est
ici non elle était ici et où est-elle
maintenant je sais pas elle est très
malade elle est très médicalisée elle
n'a plus toute sa tête elle est partie
quand je ne sais pas cette année
peut-être
et nous savons vous ne savez pas où elle
est ils ne veulent plus qu'elle parle
elle va mal qui ne veut plus qu'elle
parle écoute arrête mal à l'aise la
religieuse n'a pas envie d'en dire plus
visiblement des consignes ont été
données
et à qui on peut demander alors ici à
personne à la mer supérieure personne ne
sait personne ne le sait ici
attendez j'ai une question non non vous
partez maintenant mais une personne ne
peut pas disparaître comme ça elle n'est
pas là s'ils disent qu'elle ne peut pas
parler c'est comme si elle n'était pas
là comme s'il était morte et voilà tout
qu'est-ce que tu veux de plus
qui a donné ses consignes religieuses
qui veut le silence de se maria
l'église espagnole aurait-elle peur de
ce qu'elle pourrait raconter
la hiérarchie catholique étant tout cas
fortement montrée du doigt dans ce
scandale depuis la fin de la guerre
quasiment toutes les affaires de bébé
volés impliquent un prêtre ou une
religieuse
pourtant jusqu'à aujourd'hui pas même un
communiqué l'église espagnole est restée
muette sur le sujet nous nous adressons
à la Conférence des évêques l'organisme
représentant l'église catholique
nos demandes d'interviews sont restés
sans réponse mais ce jour-là les évêques
ont invité la presse pour parler d'un
tout autre thème une campagne pour
recueillir des fonds au centre l'évêque
chargé de la question à côté de lui le
responsable de la communication
j'ai fait plusieurs demandes d'interview
mais personne ne m'a répondu je
travaille sur le thème des bébés volés
et comme des prêtres des religieuses et
des couvents sont impliqués je voulais
connaître la position de l'Église sur le
sujet vous me prenez au dépourvu et je
ne peux pas répondre au nom de mes
frères les évêques sur un dossier qui
n'est pas le mien
il avait déjà parlé à votre niveau de
responsabilité à son Nivelle des
résultats on en a très peu parlé c'est
un thème qu'on a entendu mais de très
loin à l'issue de la conférence de
presse le Directeur de la Communication
vient directement vers moi pour une
petite leçon de morale
je crois qu'une conférence de presse
n'est pas lieu pour poser ce genre de
question vous avez vu vous avez dérangé
vos collègues vous leur avez pris du
temps pour qu'il pose leur propre
question écoutez c'est une simple
question vous me répondez et c'est tout
oui vous demandez et on vous répond que
non et stop ça devrait pas être un
problème mais sur le thème des enfants
volés en
Espagne sur le thème des bébés volés ça
ça ne vous intéresse pas écoutez si vous
continuez comme ça on va arrêter la
conversation
mais je ne comprends pas pourquoi je ne
comprends pas votre argument et bien la
plantation des vergers est un thème de
société important pour les Espagnols et
pourtant l'Église a décidé de ne pas
s'exprimer dessus mais peut-être que là
c'est un sujet qui vous dérange plus non
il y a beaucoup de thèmes qui dérangent
plus ou moins ça c'est votre opinion ici
c'est nous qui décidons
malaise au sein de l'Église catholique
qui fait le choix du silence face au
scandale
[Musique]
le gouvernement espagnol lui a décidé de
prendre les devants
pour des amorcer toute critique il a
créé un poste spécial bébé volé au sein
du ministère de la Justice
André Lounès est chargé de coordonner
les actions judiciaires en cours et de
répondre à la presse
comment est-elle scandale a-t-il pu se
dérouler sous la démocratie pourquoi la
justice se réveille-t-elle si tard pour
andrer le nièce la réponse réside dans
les débuts difficiles de la démocratie
et l'héritage de 40 années de franquisme
dans ces années là la peur est restée
présente pendant très longtemps
les gens avaient peur de porter plainte
même s'ils savaient clairement qu'on
leur avait volé un enfant
comme aujourd'hui le processus
d'adaptation a été très progressif il a
fallu du temps pour que le système
judiciaire s'adapte à la démocratie
on a dû modifier les lois une par une
rendez-vous compte la loi sur l'adoption
n'a pas changé avant 1987
c'est d'ailleurs la modification de
cette loi qui va permettre l'arrêt du
trafic à la fin des années 80
pour le ministère il faut maintenant
aller de l'avant la priorité aider à
reconstituer les familles permettre aux
maires et aux enfants volés de se
retrouver un espoir énorme devenu
réalisable depuis à peine quelques
années
cet espoir c'est celui de la Révolution
ADN nous sommes dans les environs de
Valence ce matin se déroule une de ces
réunions qui concentre tous les rêves
des familles une réunion ADN
spécialement organisée pour les bébés
volés
d'abord ce sont les mamans qui font le
test ADN ensuite c'est le tour des fils
et des filles les autres vous vous
mettez au fond
Amaya travaille pour génomica le
laboratoire chargé de récupérer les
empreintes génétiques de toutes les
victimes notamment je prends ton ADN et
après je t'explique ouvre la bouche
l'objectif croisé recouper les profils
des parents et des enfants qui se
cherchent les prélèvements se font à la
chaîne de coups de coton-tige un peu de
salive quelques secondes à peine qui
permettront peut-être des retrouvailles
l'ADN est une technologie qui permet
tout si tout est papiers sont fausses si
la date de ta naissance lieu de ta
naissance ne sont pas les bons alors
l'unique façon de savoir qui est ta
famille c'est la génétique et après il
n'y a plus de doute ce sont les seuls
résultats totalement fiables qu'on ne
peut pas remettre en cause
par an frère et sœur ou enfants adoptés
chacun cherche la pièce manquante de sa
famille ce jour-là en quelques heures à
Maya récupérera 120 profils ADN
il rejoindront les centaines d'autres
déjà stockés à Madrid au siège de
génomique
ici l'Espagne est en train de constituer
une des plus grandes banques génétiques
de toute l'Europe en moins de six mois
un millier d'empreintes ont été
récupérés elles y sont analysées
stockées et recouper après chaque
nouvelle réunion ADN
quand deux empreintes sont identiques le
laboratoire appelle les familles les
premiers miracles commencent à se
produire une dizaine de retrouvailles
ont été réalisées
[Musique]
et là
comment une mère retrouve-t-elle son
enfant des décennies après se l'être
fait voler
comment reconstruire un lien briser dès
le premier jour
l'histoire de Pilar et Louisa et celle
d'une seconde naissance
d'une mère et d'une fille qui se
découvre après 29 ans de séparation
on va à la maison ta sœur nous attend
au moment où les filmons elles se sont
retrouvés il y a moins de deux semaines
au début du mois de juillet elle
reçoivent ce coup de téléphone du
laboratoire à peine croyable et tant
espéré à la fois les analyses ADN ont
révélé qu'elles sont maires et filles
Louisa retrouve enfin l'enfant qu'on lui
avait volé
aujourd'hui les deux femmes apprennent à
mieux se connaître Louisa la mère emmène
Pilar chez une de ses sœurs biologiques
elle veut prendre son temps lui faire
rencontrer un par un les membres de sa
nouvelle famille
[Musique]
Alejandro le père adoptif de Pilar est
venu lui aussi un peu mal à l'aise il a
du mal à trouver sa place
[Musique]
ce jour-là Pilar a amené l'album de
photos de son enfance pour partager un
peu des années que sa mère n'a pas connu
regarde les deux sœurs elles ont les
mêmes joues regarde à les rendre heureux
[Musique]
et là vous aviez toutes les deux la même
coupe de cheveux avec la même raie sur
le côté
louisa est une des nombreuses victimes
du triangle de la mort à Madrid merci
célibataire on lui a volé son bébé à
Santa Cristina le jour de son
accouchement il y a tout juste 29 ans
évoqué ce moment et douloureux
l'occasion de tension entre elle et elle
les rendre le père adoptif
ça j'ai compris mais il y a quelque
chose que je ne comprends toujours pas
on vous faisait signer vous payer et
c'est tout vous partiez
nous les parents adoptifs on était
convaincus que la fille était abandonnée
qu'elle avait été laissée parce que sa
mère ne pouvait pas s'en occuper qu'elle
n'avait pas les moyens ou pourquoi que
ce soit mais on pensait que l'enfant
était abandonné pas volé
vont finalement tomber d'accord les
vraies responsables de ce trafic sont
les docteurs les religieuses ceux qui
ont joué avec la vie des uns et des
autres
[Musique]
ils ont totalement changé ma vie
la mienne et celle de beaucoup d'autres
enfants
aujourd'hui je vois ma famille et je me
dis que tout aurait pu être si différent
ils m'ont manipulé comme si j'étais un
jouet en me mettant dans la famille
qu'ils avaient choisi et passaient où
j'étais né
moi non plus en fait j'ai passé ma vie à
y penser je regardais les petites filles
dans les parcs je me disais
peut-être qu'elle n'est pas morte
peut-être qu'elle a quatre ou cinq ans
tiens c'est peut-être cet adolescente là
assise dans l'autobus j'ai été obsédé
toute ma vie par la recherche de ma
fille
après des années passées à se chercher
Louisa et Pilar ont fini par se
retrouver mais les rencontres comme
celle-là rester rare très difficile à
réaliser
[Musique]
de notre enquête nous découvrons que des
enfants ont été vendus à l'étranger
[Musique]
car le scandale des bébés volés à bel et
bien dépassé les frontières de l'Espagne
quel pays ont pu en profiter
combien d'enfants ont été envoyés au
loin et sont devenus impossibles à
retrouver c'est le témoignage de Liberia
qui nous a mis sur la piste des
adoptions internationales elle est née
dans une de ces fameuses cassacuna à
Tenerife dans les Canaries aujourd'hui
avec son avocate elle réunit ses
documents pour porter plainte contre la
mer supérieure
Liberia a été donné à l'adoption mais
tard vers l'âge de 8 ans elle est donc
une des rares enfants à pouvoir se
souvenir de ce qui se passait dans la
catacuna elle se rappelle notamment des
visites fréquentes de groupes
d'étrangers
[Musique]
ils venait de pays très différents il
nous touchait il nous regardait les
cheveux il nous touchait comme ça il
regardait nos yeux mais on ne comprenait
pas leur langue ce qu'il disait et
qu'est-ce qui se passait ensuite le
lendemain un enfant disparaissait un
enfant ou deux ça dépendait
d'après Liberia ces groupes d'étrangers
étaient toujours reçus avec déférence il
s'agissait de gens riches bien placés
suffisamment pour connaître les réseaux
avoir accès aux informations
car un bouche à oreille mondial s'est
mis en place entre milieu expatriés
médecins et couvent l'Espagne a des
relations privilégiées avec l'Amérique
latine et les États-Unis la haute
société là-bas va vite savoir que le
pays fournit des bébés
[Musique]
nous partons sur la trace d'un de ses
enfants volés de l'étranger notre
enquête nous emmène à des milliers de
kilomètres de l'Espagne de ces cliniques
et ses couvents
direction Austin la capitale
administrative du Texas dans le sud des
États-Unis
une ville universitaire ouverte dans un
des États les plus conservateurs du pays
dans l'immense banlieue d'Austin une
petite maison
c'est ici que nous rencontrons en direct
que le destin a fait naître en Espagne
mais vivre aux États-Unis
à 40 ans Randy à tout d'un Américain le
mode de vie la langue la culture
impossible de deviner ses racines
espagnoles
Randy ne les a découvertes lui-même que
très tard à la naissance de son premier
enfant quand il le présente à sa famille
un moment j'ai dit il ne nous ressemble
vraiment pas c'était une petite blague
rien de plus
et ma grand-mère m'a regardé et m'a dit
je me souviens de ces mots exacts
tu n'es pas de notre sang
j'ai dit qu'est-ce que tu veux dire
elle m'a répondu tu n'es pas mon
petit-fils biologique
alors j'ai appelé mon père
il a d'abord tout nié et finalement il a
avoué et il m'a dit cette phrase
je ne sais pas si c'était symbolique ou
si c'était important pour lui il m'a dit
si ça peut te faire du bien
sache qu'on a pris le meilleur bébé
je n'oublierai jamais ça
[Musique]
par
pièce panée au cours d'un de ses
déplacements en Espagne il le récupère
dans une clinique tenue par des
religieuses à Malaga il pèse 5000
dollars cash et le ramène aux États-Unis
[Musique]
un jour ma copine m'a dit c'est
incroyable comme ta mère s'est remise de
l'accouchement elle est toute mince
alors qu'elle vient d'accoucher et
maintenant que je sais la vérité je me
dis qu'il y avait une bonne raison à ça
l'histoire de Randy est celle d'une
adoption ratée sa mère sombre dans
l'alcool l'abandonne Randy connaîtra
l'orphelinat avant d'être récupéré par
son père aujourd'hui ses parents sont
morts alors comme des milliers
d'espagnol rendit vis dans le fantasme
de retrouver sa vraie famille il a
envoyé son ADN en Espagne et passe des
heures sur les nombreux forums de
recherche créés par des enfants volés
c'est sur Internet qu'au-delà de son
histoire rendit a pris la mesure du
scandale qui secoue toute l'Espagne
ce serait magnifique d'avoir un Happy en
pour tout le monde
mais est-ce que tout ça a changé quelque
chose pour moi non j'ai toujours ma
souffrance je veux toujours retrouver ma
mère
mais ça crée de l'empathie et un réseau
de gens qui vous soutiennent
les gens sont là les uns pour les autres
impossible de connaître exactement le
nombre de bébés volés envoyés à
l'étranger en quittant l'Espagne les
traces de ses enfants ont été perdus
leur témoignages restent exceptionnel
depuis les États-Unis Randy a décidé de
porter plainte en Espagne devant le
parquet de Malaga
comme lui de nombreuses familles ont
remis leur sort entre les mains des
juges les 1000 premières plaintes sont
déjà en cours d'instruction une première
étape seulement car ce sont des
centaines de milliers d'Espagnols qui
réclament aujourd'hui justice à la
recherche des vies qu'on leur a volé